bachelor bend the politician from
eliminating ladies to eliminating
political foes Bachelor Ben Higgins
making an unexpected move he might run
for office the Colorado independent is
reporting Ben could pursue a seat in the
Colorado House of Representatives a
local business owner named Willie
Pinkston who is currently the Republican
nominee for that spot says he will step
aside if Ben wants in he thinks Ben's
name recognition can help Republicans
win in a heavily Democratic area the 28
year old said in a statement any
decision I make regarding entering the
race will be based on what is best for
Willie his family and for Lauren and me
benin fiancee lauren Bushnell definitely
seemed to be settling into life in
colorado their latest instagrams show
the pair working on a house and politics
does seem to make sense for Ben he's
been very active in his community and
with charity work and unlike many other
bachelor alums Ben did not continue on
with reality TV most bachelors follow
the show up with Dancing with the Stars
so would you vote for Ben Higgins let me
know on Twitter
you